AMIT SINGHAL: When I was young,
I was fascinated by planes
and wanted to be a pilot.
I first got a chance
to fly on a plane
when I was in middle
school, and what I remember
is how smooth the ride was.
I did not even feel
that we were moving.
When I grew up, I had a chance
to look inside the cockpit
and I saw how complex it was.
But still, the
experience of flying
was made smooth and
easy for the passengers.
And that is how Google
Cloud Platform operates.
It has complexity
inside, but for the user,
it is simple and easy to use.
And it is reliable
like planes too.
Hi everyone, I'm Amit Singhal,
Technical Lead at Google.
Today, along with
my colleagues, we'll
talk about how Google
software defined approach,
behind its infrastructure
and products,
make it a resilient, scalable
and high performance.
We'll deep dive into
Andromeda virtual networking
and also talk about front
end systems that route
all incoming traffic.
In the end, we'll
talk about some
of the networking products.
Google Cloud Platform at high
level comprises the following.
Compute, which has Compute
Engine, App Engine, Container
Engine, and Cloud Functions.
Then we have storage,
which has several products
like Cloud SQL, BigTable, Cloud
Data Store, Spanner, et cetera.
Networking, with infrastructure
for virtualization and load
balancers, and several
products like cloud VPN,
routers, firewalls, et cetera.
Analytics, with
products like BigQuery,
Dataflow, Dataproc, machine
learning, et cetera.
One key advantage Google
Cloud customers get
is reliability and
scale of running
on same shared
infrastructure that powers
all Google services, like
search, ads, maps, Gmail, et
cetera, built with years of
experience and state of the art
technology.
Google has been a pioneer
in large scale distributed
systems for more than a decade.
Many of Google's
innovations have completely
changed the standard
computing paradigms
and spawned new industries.
MagProduce started
big data revolution,
Cloud DataFlow is
built over that.
BigTable was one of the first
NoSQL database implementations,
and Cloud BigTable
is built over that.
Then we have Cloud
GCS over Colossus.
Cloud BigQuery is
built over Dremel.
Spanner is a wide area
consistent data base service
that allows you to run
transactions across the globe,
and Cloud Spanner is
provided over that.
All of these services are
provided through gRCP APIs.
We use software defined
approach across all our tickets
of Cloud, and they
share similar concepts.
We would love to talk
about all the areas,
but in the interest
of time, we'll
focus more on the
networking in this talk.
Google is constantly
innovating in networking space.
This is a timeline of
the major milestones.
We have taken software
defined approach early on,
in almost everything we do.
Maglev was a software
load balancer
that routes all incoming
traffic to collect back ends.
B4 is our WAN network
built using SDN principles.
Jupiter is our software
defined DataCenter networking,
and Andromeda is our software
defined network virtualization
technology.
Why Google Cloud networking?
It provides high throughput,
up to 16 gigabits per second
and under 100 microsecond
latency between VMs.
You can spin up thousands
of VMs within a few minutes,
and we provide hitless
upgrades and feature rollouts
without impacting customer
workloads with our VM migration
technology.
One of the key advantages
of our networks
are that they're global,
which allows customers
to have VMs in different regions
communicate over private IPs.
And we provide network functions
as a service, like load
balancing, routing,
security, CDN, et cetera.
We talked about why,
and now let's look
at what is Google
Cloud networking.
Like I said, we at
Google use software
defined networking
as DN in everything
we do for networking, but Google
Cloud networking is not just
that.
First of all, it is built
upon our state of the art WAN
connecting our state of
the art data centers.
It is network virtualization and
isolation using SDN principles.
It has to scale to
support thousands of VMs
for thousands of
customers and provide
customizable functionality
through APIs.
All this together make
Google Cloud network.
So software defined
network virtualization.
What are the benefits
for the user?
It provides faster
provisioning times
with centralized controller,
faster roll out of new features
without depending on new
hardware, high availability
using hierarchical
control plane.
In next few slides,
we'll talk about
how virtual networks
are different
from physical networks, and what
are the unique challenges that
creates.
Overlay virtual networks
over physical network,
and we'll also talk about
our centralized hierarchical
control plane.
Some high level background on
how physical networks look.
You have racks of servers.
We call them hosts here,
shown in green boxes.
They connect to top of
the rack switch TORs.
TORs connect to each other
through one or more routers
in the middle.
Important property
of these networks
is address aggregation
and locality.
That limits the radius of
layer to broadcast domain,
and that is also
used by distributor
routing protocols and
switches to learn and make
forwarding decisions.
With Cloud, physical data center
networks become multi-tenant.
You can imagine there
is a logical switch
for virtual network.
Now one way to support this is
by extending the whole stack
to become aware of multitenancy
and use tenant key--
in this case we call it VNet
here for virtual network--
in making all
forwarding decisions.
Now this need changes to
physical switches and routers,
and also make routing
protocols for getting
this new information.
But even if we do that, what
makes this approach difficult
is that as customers
spin out new VMs,
they can be scheduled anywhere
on the physical network,
depending on the availability.
And there is no location
based address aggregation.
Network virtualization
takes a different approach.
Instead of relying on dynamic
discovery based protocols,
it creates a logical
overlay for each customer,
hiding details of
the physical network.
Using encapsulation and host
port information for each VM,
point to point flows
are created between VMs.
Now centralized controller
is key to implementing
such approach.
Now let's look at workflow
for VM creation and network
provisioning.
In this case, owner
of the orange network
wants to add one more VM.
He sends the request to
configuration manager,
which cause computer
control plane to start
a VM on some host with
available capacity.
That information is given to
the Configuration Manager, which
calls the network control plane
with the host port information
of the newly created VM.
It then sends a message
to all hosts which
have VM from this network,
and point to point flows
are created from this new
VM to the existing VMs.
In this slide, I'd
like to emphasize
the hierarchical implementation
of our configuration
and control plane.
Configuration plane
serves all user requests
by calling appropriate
backend modules.
It is divided into three levels,
global, regional, and zonal.
Even backend control plane
is divided into three levels,
global, regional, and zonal.
User requests are routed
to various backend jobs
at different hierarchies.
Now the goal is to
keep most configuration
and provisioning at
zonal level to limit
the blast radius of any failure,
and then regional, and only
a few services to be
global when necessary.
We talked about
configuration, now
let's look at control
and data plane.
Fabric Manager gets all requests
for network provisioning.
Again, tasks are divided at
regional and zonal level.
Their VM controllers,
which manages all the VMs
inside customer network and
those VM controllers are zonal,
it creates flows between all the
endpoints on a virtual network,
so these end points
can communicate.
Our next speaker will talk in
more detail about this part.
There are Cloud
front-end tasks that
provide connectivity to
Google services for VMs
through internal network,
without having to travel
through public network.
End points inside
virtual network
can send traffic to internet
through Google edge routers.
And finally, all
incoming traffic
first hits network load
balancer and appropriately
routed to correct endpoint
in either customer network
or Google front-end
tasks for Google.
Services.
And now, I'll hand over to my
colleague and next speaker,
Krishnan to talk more about
Andromeda virtual networking.
SRINIVAS KRISHNAN Thanks Amit.
In this portion of the talk,
I will be covering details
on the network, virtualization
of the structure
that powers GCP.
This is a great opportunity
for us, especially me,
to represent the work of an
amazing team here at Google.
So network
virtualization for GCP
internally is
known as Andromeda.
Andromeda powers the virtual
networking infrastructure
and a lot of our network
product offerings.
Amin Vahdat, Google Fellow,
has presented our Andromeda
at ONF earlier,
and today we will
be uncovering the nuts and bolts
of how Andromeda's actually
built, especially its
core features that
allows us to build scalable
and high performance systems.
So what you see behind
me is GCP's network.
It is one of the largest
networks among cloud providers.
It is globally spread out,
there are six regions, 18 zones,
and we will be announcing
12 more regions in 2017.
Network virtualization
is to build,
to make it easy for
you, the customer,
to leverage this
amazing network.
This talk is in two halves.
First I'll be doing a deep
dive into our control plane.
First I'll be talking about
how we provide isolation
across virtual networks.
In this example, there
are two virtual networks
which share the same
physical infrastructure.
I will be giving details on how
network virtualization allows
these networks to have
their own tenant space.
I will also be talking about
how we can scale up on demand.
GCP, we have done
experiments where
we can show 100k VMs can be
spun up in 184 milliseconds.
I shall also be
going into details
about how we achieve
high availability targets
and do three nines in a single
zone, four nines in a region,
and five nines globally.
Next, I will also be going into
details about our unique data
plane.
Our data plane has
core network functions
that bake directly into it,
for example load balancing.
We're also constantly evolving,
and we are building new network
functions into our data plane.
I'll be talking into details
and how we achieve that
by using live
migration, and also
what we call hitless
dataplane upgrades.
So let's dive right in.
As Amit mentioned, our control
plane is built as a hierarchy.
Sits at the very top, where
we call cluster manager.
And cluster manager
performs many tasks.
It is responsible for
configuring things
like storage, compute, and
in our case, networking.
Below that sits
the fabric manager,
and you can see a
theme going on here.
It's again split up into
regional and zonal control
planes.
Andromeda comes below it,
which is VM controllers,
and what the fabric manager,
the VM controller's job,
is to expose a high
level API, which
is used to configure the
virtual networks and also
different network functions.
Right below it sits the OFE,
which is the open flow layer.
It takes our API abstractions
and then converts them
into OpenFlow
programming constructs
that we can use to
program a switching layer.
The switching layer shown
here is built directly
into each VM host.
It has a programmable switch,
which is based on open vswitch,
and it has a core
data plane, which
is responsible for
packet processing.
So now let's take a deeper look
on how you actually achieve
the scale of a control plane.
I've zoomed in here, a zonal
view of our control plane
and a single host
that's managing.
A zone shares the same
hardware failure domain
and also has the same
network connectivity.
To guard against
machine failures,
the VM controllers
are replicated.
It has one singly master,
[INAUDIBLE] selected master
and two standbys to take
over at any given time.
We also sharded the
OFEs, and a single OFE
maintains shards,
multiple VM host shards.
And we take this sharding
concept one step further.
We replicate our
entire control plane
so that each VMC also
manages other racks
on other set of hosts.
This allows us to
smear processing
across these different replicas.
Finally this also allows
for easy horizontal scaling.
If you want to add new
capacity to our zones,
let's say we bring up a
whole new set of racks,
all we need to do is spin up
a new replica of our control
plane while you have a new
capacity can be announced.
It is as simple as that.
So as GCP has grown and our
offerings have expanded,
the network programming has
become more and more complex.
We started off with
a very simple model.
It's a pre-programmed model,
it looks something like this.
It's a full mesh.
It is very simple,
consistent, and predictable
to think about in latency,
but it has one problem.
It has quadratic
scaling in terms of VMs.
So any time, for a network, if
you're going to add a new VM,
you've got to do this full mesh.
That means you've got to go
ahead and program OpenFlow
rules in every single VM host.
We can do better than that.
So we started looking.
The first thing we evaluated
were the traditional OpenFlow
model, where the control plane
waits for the first packet,
and based on the packet,
we install our flows.
Now this gets much better
than the pre-programmed model,
but it has
unpredictable latency,
and you can imagine why.
It is dependent on the
control plane capacity.
It also exposes
the control plane
to packet floods from the hosts.
So what we did is we combined
the best features of all
these different
things, and we came up
with the model, what
we call Hoverboards.
Hoverboards are a
software gateway,
and we you can think of this
as a default router network.
We don't need to
pre-program our flows.
As soon as the VMs
come up in a network,
the packets start
egressing and ingressing
through the software
gateway, so there is really
no warm up time.
Small networks remain as before.
We borrowed this from
the pre-program model,
as I mentioned before, it is
simple and it's consistent.
For this Hoverboards, as the
flows that are going through it
grow larger, we also
added the ability
to offload them directly
back to the host.
And this allows our
software gateways to scale,
as well as giving predictable
latency and throughput.
From this, I'm going to move
onto the data plane now.
So we've been working
on this for a while.
The first step
was Andromeda 1.0,
but our data plane was in the
kernel, and it had openvswitch.
To that, we added
offloads for performance
and we introduced
live migration.
This was Andromeda 1.5.
Next is what we have the
current version, which is 2.0.
It is a large evolution, where
we removed the entire data
plane from the kernel
to use the space.
With it came a huge
boost in performance
and also a large increase
in release velocity.
And I'll be talking about
how we achieved that.
In the next few iterations,
we pushing hard and hypervisor
bypass.
The first version that
we're working on right
now is 2.1, which
allows the guest OS
to bypass the hypervisor
and talk directly
to a userspace NIC.
In the future, we'll
have full bypass,
where the guest OS
will be directly
talking to hardware NIC, giving
you full Hypervisor bypass.
So one of the goals when
we built this new data
plane Andromeda 2.0 was
to enable native hardware
performance in software.
So the way we did
that is we introduced
what we call a fast path.
And a fast path has a single
CPU that's busy polling
and it's optimized
for performance.
It can sustain up to two
million packets per second.
CPU intensive operations,
we moved off the fast path
into what we call coprocessors.
Coprocessors have
this unique ability
to scale with the technology
we call CPU attribution.
And finally, all of
this is controlled
by the on host control
plane using openvswitch.
So you might have a
question as to why
did we build this
new user space,
and I shall mention three
distinct advantages.
The first one is security.
Our data plane runs without
any root privileges.
Unlike a monolithic
kernel, it also
has a very small attack
surface because it's
built for one purpose, so we
can do continuous fuzz testing
on it.
It also comes built
with ASLR and has stack
protected memory to prevent
against memory corruption.
It also gives us
improved robustness.
So if you think of this, if you
have a kernel networking stack
bug, it'll take down
your entire machine.
In this case, it's
a userspace process,
so it'll just come right up.
Finally, one of the biggest
advantages we have is rapid
releases.
We can upgrade the
entire data plane
underneath without having to
either live migrate the VMs
or do a machine grain.
It's not just performance
that we optimize for.
You also want a fully
programmable dataplane.
What I've shown here is a
dataplane with a flow table.
Now the flow table
can take a five table,
or a three table key match and
has extremely extensible packet
actions.
The VM controller has
full control over this.
It can program it,
and in this case,
it is programming you through
openflow, through openvswitch
by just programming, let's say
an encap and a decap action.
We also have extended
the openvswitch,
so we have Google
extension frameworks
that allows us to provide state
flow functions like sticky load
balancing.
You can do things like
stats and filtering
and policy enforcement directly
inside the openvswitch.
We also have extended
the coprocessor API,
it's extremely extensible.
Anything that requires
inline packet processing,
for example traffic
shaping, DoS and abuse,
the built in [INAUDIBLE]
inside the coprocessor,
and has API exposed as well.
And any new features
we're actively developing
are getting implemented in
this coprocessor framework.
So next, I want to
talk about performance.
So what is the
advantage that you
get when we move from
Andromeda 1.0 point onwards?
So first up, throughput.
We improved throughput by
over 5x from Andromeda 1.0
to Andromeda 2.1.
So currently without
throttling, you
can get 25 gbps in
a 40 G NIC setup.
Just note though, customers are
throttled at 60 gbps overall.
The system provides
consistent performance
across different
hardware platforms.
We also improved latency.
TCP roundtrip
latency reduced by 7x
from when we move from
Andromeda 1.0 to Andromeda 2.1.
Finally, CP efficiency.
We measure CP efficiency
as cycles per byte,
and this combines the
receive side guest,
the receive side host,
even the central side host
and the center side VM, and we
improved it by a factor of 8
giving more CPU to the guest
to use for other functions.
And with that, we wrap up the
Andromeda section of this,
and I'll be handing you over to
my colleague Assar Westerlund
to discuss how we take
the software approach
all the way to the front.
ASSAR WESTERLUND:
Thank you, Sri.
I will be talking about how
this cloud networking fits
into the internet at large.
So where do we connect
to the internet?
This is a map behind me
here of where we have POPs,
or points of presence, where
we pair with other networks.
Our global network expands to
the world and connected data
centers.
But to make sure
it's truly useful,
we want to connect it to
ISPs and be closer to users.
We are pairing with ISPs at over
100 interconnection facilities
and at about 90 internet
exchange points.
About 80 of those are used
for the load balancing
and CDN features that
I will talk about.
As an indication of
the distances here
and being a network folks, we
measure at the milliseconds,
Cedexis is just the
third party affiliation
of our CDN for the
cloud offering,
and their numbers are
that the media latency
for fetching an
object from the CDN
is 42 milliseconds
across the world.
And then 90 percentile
of that is 148, so not
that much higher as it is.
And like lots of other things,
that we care about the tail
as well.
So what does this look like.
This is an example
here behind me
of how you would
configure global load
balancing into the cloud.
One feature we have is that
we have a global IP address.
So when you configure
a load balancer,
you get one global IP address
that is valid for all users,
and more importantly it gets
good service to all the users.
So this means you
don't have to do
any DNS based load balancing.
The only thing you
need to do is put
in a record in your DNS
server of the choice
with that address.
And as you can see
on the picture here,
your users will get redirected--
will get content from as nearby
as we can make them.
So the Des Moines users get
connected to US central,
and the Mumbai users get
connected to an Asia region,
regardless of anything
you have to do.
The only thing you have
to do is to make sure
that you use this IP address.
And this is, again,
like my co-presenters
talked about before, built
on the existing shared
infrastructure that we at Google
use for all the Google services
that you are used to.
And nearby the user, we
allow you to have a CDN,
it's a one checkbox
option if you
want to have CDN with your
load balancing offering.
We can do different routing on
a per request level on each URL,
and I will talk more about that.
And the latency matters for us.
Latency matters for
users of web services.
We have known this with search,
for example, for a long time.
Any of those matter
for micro services,
if you build your
infrastructures,
that you are calling
different things,
being able to get back
soon, is important.
So that is something
that we care about.
So this is an overall picture
of what looks like at the edge.
Your phone in the ISPs
network on the left
here is connecting to
your global IP address.
We pair with this ISP, either
directly or indirectly,
at some point using the
border gateway protocol,
and in the edge POP, we have
a little bit of infrastructure
so that we can serve
cash content from the CDN
and we can terminate a TCP
connection from the user there,
which brings a performance
advantage in that it's
a shorter connection,
retransmissions are much faster
and you get better
performance over it.
And then over on the
right, further away
from the user in
the general case,
you have your data center, where
you run the actual VM jobs.
So I'll go into more
detail on these steps.
So the advantage for
doing this in software,
like you heard
from Amir and Sri,
is that we are very
used to building systems
that scale out.
We build-- we scale up
a number of components.
We can have a larger
amount of traffic,
larger amount of volume.
It scales with new
hardware, gets better,
and since the system is built
to deal with failures, one
of those not being there,
we just work around that
and we keep going.
Also, this is a
similar mechanism
that we use for pushing updates.
We can take one
component off, we
can push a new version of binary
to it, bring it back up again,
it gets part of the mesh,
it gets running again.
And we can do rolling
upgrades that way,
without anybody noticing
that anything was down.
So at some point, we
start with version x,
and then slowly,
assuming everything
goes well, we end
up with a version x
plus one with the new features.
And if something
doesn't go well,
we just go back to
version x again.
And everything here,
being described here,
is also integrated into
Configuration Manager that's
what we talked about earlier.
So all these components
get orchestration
together to make
sure the whole data
plane works from end to end.
So how does it work to have
this one global address that
is usable from anywhere?
Mostly people talk of this
as an anycast address.
The large feature we have down
here is to make it stabilized,
so that if things change and
routing changes over time,
that doesn't have an impact.
The way this works
technically is pretty simple.
We announce a block of addresses
to all our peers for the UP.
For each ISP, they
get to figure out
what routes do they have for
this block to reach Google.
And oftentimes it's as a
long list of different ones.
They get to choose,
and typically they
choose the shortest path, which
is the smallest number of hops.
But they also have a
number of other paths
they can use if that one isn't
available for some reason.
So in general,
your user's traffic
ends up at the narrowest POP
by network distance, which
should be not that far away.
And then there's a fallback
if that POP isn't available,
or it goes somewhere else.
Routing flaps, which
means that routing changes
over short periods of
time and goes back,
is fairly common, which
makes it hard to deal
with these anycast addresses
for TCP and URL general.
So we have a special
mechanism that we
have built to deal with that,
I will talk about later.
So these are the things
that we put in a POP.
We have two routers
for redundancy,
that are the connection
to the other networks.
And then we have two more steps.
First we have a network
level load balancer
that does routing
on TCP connections.
We call it Maglev.
This is something
we built in house.
So the function of that is to
map each incoming user's TCP
connection to one of
the next of the boxes.
The GFE, or Google
front-end for short,
is the HTTP base
load that we built.
So that is the first
level that can actually
take the URL apart and act
based on the full constant URL.
We install CDN in
these publications
as well so that
for cache content,
we can serve it
very quickly back
and we don't even need to
send it to a data center.
So let's talk more
about the Maglev.
The Maglev is basically
taking five tuple hash
and mapping that to
one instance of GFE.
So that means that we
keep that connection
at the same instance, we
have all the cache content,
all the state and that
point as long as we can.
So the goal is to each user,
and then a load balance fashion
hits one particular GFE.
And there's multiple
mechanisms that
go into making that happen.
Once we have established
a connection,
we keep track of where we
sent that particular user
and we'll keep sending
it there to make sure
that it's a stable connection.
If it's a new connection, so
we haven't seen it before,
then we use consistent
hashing to make
sure we have a
uniform way of making
that decision across the board,
across this ever changing set
of load balancers.
To deal with these route
flaps as I mentioned before,
we have a map that says
for each client prefix,
where do you expect
this to land?
And if a Maglev
gets traffic that
isn't supposed to
land there, we'll
forward it to the other Maglev.
And once that route flap
isn't there anymore,
the user won't see
any difference,
but the other Maglev will
be doing the work now.
Maglevs are only on
the inbound path,
so all traffic goes
back to the user,
goes out directly, which
makes it more efficient,
they only have to deal
with one side of the flow.
And if you do network level
load balancing for your cloud
features, the Maglev will be
the ones sending direct traffic
jacket to your VMs.
And they get to know
what IPs to deal
with from this
configuration manager
that we talked about before.
So these also offer
routes for kernel bypass
on normal servers, and they
can do this at line rate.
So this is the flow
for each Maglev.
For each incoming packet, it
looks at the target IP address
and says is this an
address I'm dealing with,
am I doing load balance
for this address?
If not, we can just drop it.
If it is, we look it up in this
map that says for this prefix,
it should be in this location.
And if that location
is not me, well I
know where to send it and I
must pass it on to that one
and that one will do
the right thing with it.
And this-- we
rebuild this client
IP map so that we know
where to expect traffic.
And then we look it up in the
connection tracking, and says,
have we seen traffic
from this client before?
If so, we know where to send it.
If not we use consistent
hashing to figure out
where it should go and we
annotate that in the connection
tracking, so subsequent
packets on that TCP connection
can go there directly.
The next step in the
Edge POP is the GFE.
It's a proxy or a reverse
proxy, so it terminates
TCP connection, which
as I said before helps
with making a short
connection to the user
and improving latency and
improving recovery time if we--
I think I dropped
packets on that link.
A terminating HTTP,
and by HTTP, I
mean the whole family of HTTP,
like protocols, so 1.1, 2.0.
GRPC is a Google RPC
system, open source,
built on top of HTTP/2.0.
And QUIC is basically
the next version of HTTP,
running on UDP instead of TCP.
Once it actually has the
full hostname in the URL,
it knows what is cacheable
and what's not cacheable,
and it can consult
the cache and see,
do I have this object
cache, and if so,
I can flow it from
there directly.
You can also do different things
depending on the full URL.
So you can have different
mappings for different parts
of the URL space.
By default it will send
traffic to the nearest region,
again to reduce latency.
If that region is at
capacity and can't handle it,
we'll send it somewhere else.
And that capacity
can either be, you
configure each VM saying this is
how much traffic it can handle,
or we can just look
at the CPU list
and say oh, well these
VMs are overloaded,
we should not send
them more traffic.
And to reduce latency, we also
health check VMs ahead of time
before we send them
any traffic, so we
know that they're up and
healthy, so that those requests
don't have to wait.
So here's an example.
Assuming you have
a website where
you have your assets, your
images, your HTML, your CSS,
your JavaScript.
Instead of serving
them from a web server,
you can just put them
in a storage bucket
and tell us when to put
up your load balancer.
Everything that starts with
static, please go and fetch it,
it's in this storage bucket.
And that means that we don't
even need to go to your VM
at all about these requests.
We can send them
directly to the storage,
which is a scaleable solution
that grows by itself.
And you can have
different portions
of the URL space can also get
sent to different sets of VMs.
So if you have some level
of different content
for different processing,
you can send it
to different places.
So this is the overall picture.
The GFE over on the edge,
after having consulted a CDN
and knows it's not
a cached content,
it consults the global
load balancer on the bottom
there, which will tell it, well
we have capacity in this zone,
or we have capacity
in this zone.
And a GFE also tells the
global load controller
how much traffic it has sent, so
they can update its accounting
and know not to send
too much traffic.
In each zone, inside
a zone, there's
a health checker
that goes and checks
the VMs that are registered to
be backend for load balancer
to make sure that
they are healthy.
And they'd report that back
to global load controller
so we wouldn't send
traffic to a VM that is not
up yet or not running healthy.
From a networking point of
view, the GFE looks to your VMs
like a normal machine
on the network.
It is using a public IP
address that's not routable,
and you can think of
it as GFEs actually
forming part of all your VMIDS.
But GFE can tell apart
one from the other.
So from your VMs and
your web servers running
on your VMs point
of view, it just
looks like a normal host on that
network is sending it traffic.
And this is all using
the virtual networking
in from Andromeda that
we earlier talked about.
So to tie this back, what we
really care about and would
like you to enjoy, and
your users enjoy well
is low latency, and
we have built this
in multiple different ways.
First of all, we have
an extensive network
of pairing points so that we end
up being close to your users.
If we can't sort from CDN
and we have to go back to VM,
we'll go to the nearest region,
again to reduce latency.
We make sure everything
is warmed up,
so all you have
on the connection,
we are ready to send it on,
we have done the handshakes
and we know that that VM
is healthy and serving
and we can send it to request.
And we also have done a bunch
of work on different protocols.
The list of HTTP
family, particulars I
listed earlier, that are all
aimed at reducing latency.
As an example here,
we did a blow test
across three
different zones where
we pushed up the load test
to 1.3 million requests
per second.
And to me the present thing is
not that line, which is great,
but you can see how quickly we
were able to get to that line,
right.
We were able to scale
things up very quickly.
Now next up, Amit
is back and he's
going to talk to you
how we have built
all kinds of different
networking products
based on this infrastructure.
AMIT SINGHAL: Thanks Assar.
Let's look inside
the software based
design of some our
networking parts now.
First part, I'll talk about
this cloud router and VPN.
BGP and IPsec VPN is
often used by enterprises
to provide multisite
connectivity.
One of these sites can also
be your cloud provider.
In a typical
deployment, VPN and BGP
are in the same hardware box.
BGP routing protocol
automatically
learns about the
changing topology
on the remote site and
programs the hardware box
with forwarding decisions
for outgoing traffic.
And all servers, or
VMs, send traffic
to this box, which then encrypts
and sends it the other side.
In GCP, there is no
hardware box involved.
And BGP and VPN
running separate tasks
providing control and
data plane separation.
Cloud router tasks
that runs BGP programs
and learns routes from the
remote peer directly on VMs.
And tell VMs to send
traffic directly
to the right VPN task for
those destinations, which then
sends it to the other side.
Our implementation provides
isolated and customizable
routing and VPN functionality
for each customer,
running inside their
own virtualized network.
We maintain a pool of
free router and VPN
tasks, which are
ready to be allocated
to any virtual network
when the request comes.
When Cloud VPN request comes, it
is forwarded by config manager
to the VPN manager,
which then allocates
a free task for this VPN.
Information about
this allocated task
is also sent to Fabric Manager,
which then further programs
other modules downstream.
Now when the cloud router
creation request comes,
it is forwarded to a
routing manager, which again
allocates a free routing task.
And the information is
sent to Fabric Manager
for programming the data plane.
At the end of this, there's
a direct connectivity
between your VM's
router and VPN as part
of your virtual network.
Now let's look at what happens
in case there's a failure.
If for any reason
router task fails,
routing manager identifies
that and allocates
one more from the free pool, and
also updates Andromeda flows.
Routing manager and data path
also preserves the routes
for GBC the whole time, so
traffic is not impacted.
Internet load balancing.
This is a typical multi-tier
deployment for web services.
Their front end web server, for
solving UI and static content,
backend application
in business layer
for dynamic content processing.
And both these layers need
to scale out with demand.
You can't forget external
load balancing of a public IP
to distribute request
your front-end instances.
And front-end will
further need to distribute
these requests for
dynamic processing
to one of the backend servers.
And we want to do this
in a load balance way.
And for this, we provide
manage internal load
balancing our private IPs.
Here we compare how our
implementation differs
from a typical load balancer.
Not only there is a
hardware box or task
to which our traffic is sent
which then load balances
between available backends.
Now drawbacks for this approach
are single point of failure,
and load balancer itself
can become chokepoint
for handling all traffic.
Therefore we got rid
of the middle box.
Each client, using three or five
tuple consistent hashing picks
a backend for each connection.
Load balances provision
inside each client
as a customizable
network function.
Internal load balancer is fully
programmable through the API.
Let's look at the
configuration flow.
In addition to components for
conservation and control plane
we have seen so far, this
health checking infrastructure.
When you configure load
balancer with list of backends,
health checker is asked
to monitor their health.
Objects are sent to VM
controller, and based on those,
it programs client VMs with
the right load balancing
configuration.
Client can then send traffic
directly to the backends.
Now I'll talk about
Network Peering.
This is a new feature which
was recently released in alpha
and will be done soon.
It allows you to
peer at two networks
so that VMs in
those networks can
communicate with each other.
Common use would be software as
a service for our GCP platform.
In this example,
say Google wants
to provide a cloud service
to its consumers, consumer
1 and consumer 2.
For reasons of isolation,
building model, et cetera.
It is preferred to spin
up a separate network,
hosting service instances
for each customer.
And then peer that network
with the corresponding consumer
network.
At this point, each
customer can access
the service Google provided
for them across a peer link.
Peering works for networks
within the same organization
as well as across organization.
Only restriction is that
subnetwork ranges in peering
networks should not overlap.
Peering implementation provides
isolation with connectivity.
We talked about VM
controller earlier.
There is an Endpoint
Manager game controller
that handles all the updates
given to it by Fabric Manager.
It gives endpoints for each
network, the per network flow
handler that creates all
the flows for the network.
Now for peering, we make
endpoint managers smarter
to understand peering
confrontation.
Which make network
handlers aware of endpoints
in peer networks also.
These network handlers
then also cleared floors
for sending traffic to
endpoints in peer network.
But each network can still
control what kind of traffic
they can receive,
from peer network
through ingress firewall rules.
So this how we provide
isolation with connectivity.
Peering was implemented
as network function
with big feature turn
around, by modifications
in only the centralized control
plane in a true SDN way.
There are many more networking
features in GCP like multi NIC,
IP addressing, firewalls,
that we could not
cover here due to time.
But before closing, I
want to introduce Google's
virtual private cloud, VPC.
Google provides unique
VPC characteristics.
It provides global connectivity
for VMs in multiple regions,
so that they can talk to
each other or private IPs.
It is shareable across
multiple projects
and some Network ranges can
be extended with demand.
It also provides access
to Google services
without traversing
public network.
There is also full talk later
in the evening on this topic.
To summarize, what
are the benefits
of Google Cloud platform.
It provides on demand
access to compute, storage,
and networking.
High availability and uptimes,
high throughput, low latency,
network functions
as a service, it
has been using same
infrastructure and innovations
that powered Google services,
and will deliver products
at the speed of software.
To learn more, these
are some other talks
which will be happening
this evening or tomorrow.